your favorite footballer now I think I'm
gonna go with the brainular Kevin De
bruyne yeah watching him I'm real Anna
light and bappa is on I said before
Sterling's rapid when I played against
Sterling he can run but he is another
level yeah I was in a box of Lewandowski
yeah first session yeah but that was
like yeah yeah it's probably my best
session I've had all years
when the Argentina Poland fixtures come
out
um I said to martinus straight away get
me that shirt yes I followed him and he
had a bag and it had messy shirt in it
yeah I think everyone in the Villa Squad
yeah who's that would say I'm the best
golfer at the club who's your not being
big edit but I am
we should go through karaoke song
um Robbie Williams Oh which one Angels
yeah how does that go sad away
foreign
[Music]
International Matty cash thank you so
much thank you so much for coming on
Matt honestly really honored to have you
here we really do appreciate it
um there's only one place to start Aston
Villa are flying
tell me what an Earth is going on yeah
to be fair the last the last few weeks
have been really good
um to be fair though obviously we
brought in a new manager who's fantastic
um really good style of play and it's
paying off yeah we're on fire at the
minute to be honest so hopefully a long
way to continue why do you think it is
like the season's going the way it's
going at the moment is it just a buzz
around the club what's it down here I
think there's there's many things really
um as I said them bringing in a
fantastic coach with with great coaching
staff around him is a is a massive major
part of it
um and yeah there's been a few
challenges obviously away from home we
didn't pick up great results and we we
never sort of really went on a way run
and and making Villa Park of Fortress as
well I think when you've got a when
you've got a place at home like that
with the atmosphere every week the the
45 43 000 whatever it is every week that
they bring the voices having that to
play as a major part of it as well so
um yeah a few different things really
he's an elite manager isn't he like when
you think about unai Emery's record I
think if you were to think about like
the top managers in the league I'd say
that he is he is in the very top two
couple of categories you know he is he
is up there comparable to the very best
have you noticed the difference has he
been pivotal to sort of elevating the
the club and the club's Ambitions yeah
he's a Lee he's one of the best you'll
get I think
um obviously as a player when you when
you hear a manager coming in and and the
first thing you look at is his style of
play and um and and obviously he's had
massive clubs before being at Arsenal
PSG Villarreal he done an amazing job
um and yeah obviously you can hear about
it but then there's another thing when
you're working with him and um yeah his
style of play the way years the coaches
he's got around him the team he's got is
is massive as well
um and yeah every day we're learning
really there's no sort of there's no
hiding places every day you go to work
it's the work it's not to just sort of
Let It Go by um and I think that's
another part of the reason why we've won
six in the last eight
um and yeah things are looking really
good at Villa I think it's about time as
well we've obviously been frustrated the
last however many seasons
um spent a lot of money bought some
fantastic players in and it sort of
hasn't really worked out really but now
it's sort of coming together
um and hopefully we can keep the keep
the Run going keep the ball keep the
ball moving and doing well yeah and
what's the ambition now what are you
hoping for by the end of this season
well it's like obviously it's a cliche
to say take every game as it comes
um I think that's when you're at a big
club and players sort of people are sort
of the players what what sort of the
ambition the club I think everyone knows
the ambition the size of the club
outside the top six I think Villas up
there with with the biggest
um and yeah obviously as I said we spent
a lot of money and and we need to sort
of try and climb the table so I think
we're off obviously three points off six
now
um as I said on a really good run so I
think yeah the ambition is to try and
get in the top six I think that's the
that's the main aim um I've said in many
interviews before that the building
block obviously we stayed up three four
years ago I think it was four or four
seasons ago we stayed up in the Premier
League by obviously on the last day yeah
um yeah and like the build obviously you
need to build a sort of you need to
build a
like a bridge really to try and get
yourself to the next platform and I
think we're at that now yeah and what
about for you personally what's your
what's your goals for the season yeah
I've always got goals really
um I think obviously coming off the back
of a World Cup I want to just keep
improving keep playing
um obviously young is doing fantastic at
the minute he's in the team and as I
said yeah try and get back in the team
is obviously one of the the main ones at
the minute for me
um but yeah I think I've had a good
season I think at the World Cup I played
well I just want to keep my form really
um and yeah try and try and Achieve that
and and you mentioned uh Batman young
lady do you enjoy that little battle you
know trying to get one number one spot
yeah I think Young is like young he's
the best they'll come really I think
he's like so experienced in the game
he's 38 but I tell him every day he
trains like a 20 year old
um yeah no yeah I think it's it's
important that you have competition in
your place you need to sort of fight for
your place it can't come easy especially
at a big Club as well you need you need
two players in every position that can
start and I think a villa we've got that
so yeah yeah it's nice to have
competition and it's good to see yungi
doing well I want that I want the team
to win I want I want us to climb the
table and then when I get my chance I
need to prove that I can do it do you
think it's very important to have
players like young around the school you
know just players that are experienced
they know what it takes to win they have
true pedigree prove and pedigree do you
think players like that really help and
help help the overall Ambitions of the
club yeah for sure I think like you look
at youngy's CV he's played at man united
for how many years he's played so many
Premier League games The Experience he
brings in the group and you see it on a
day-to-day basis in training he wants to
win every time
um and that's sort of what I want to be
like and that's what I am like really I
need to like look at Players like that
see the career he's had and to learn of
them because that's how you learn you
learn obviously obviously off top
managers but you learn off top teammates
as well so
um yeah having him around in my spot we
talk about football loads we've got a
really good relationship and to be to be
having him in my position with me
fighting for me he's fantastic
amazing should we um if it's okay with
you we'd like to do some quick fire
questions yeah yeah where we're just
going to find out a little bit more
about you yeah so we'll start with who
do you who did you support when you were
a kid Chelsea are that did yeah yeah I
sort of Chelsea but then I no as I got a
bit older I changed to ask you can't do
that
can we edit that it's just making don't
make the correct answer
but why why Chelsea I don't know I think
um yeah just growing I love Lampard I
loved him when I was a young kid
um so I think that was one of the main
reasons why I'd done that yeah man after
my own heart
um who's your favorite oh you just I
suppose you've answered it uh Lampard
growing up was your favorite but um what
about favorite footballer now
favorite footballer now
um
and it's exclude Villa as well actually
now go on we'll include them in as well
if you're on favorite footballer now I
think I'm gonna go with the brain you
know Kevin De bruyne yeah watching him
unreal and I like them as well yeah yeah
but yeah
fancy playing against it
if we were to look through your phone
book Now who is the most famous
footballer in the uh context footballer
footballer anyone
uh
uh I saw over Gerard or lewandowskina oh
look at that he's showing off now
yeah
one of them that's class um and who's
the most famous non-footballer in your
phone book fave famous non-footballer oh
I feel like he's got an answer here but
he's debating whether to share it yeah
something like Kim Kardashians
um honestly I wouldn't know no no I'll
have to have a look or I think um
we'll come back to it we'll come back
yeah
I've got a few famous people but like
I'll have a look
what about away from football what do
you like doing how do you spend your
time to be fair yeah away from football
um I try and keep it in the sports
industry I love snooker yeah I've got a
table at home so I'm always playing it
sort of takes your mind off football as
well obviously
not having a kids or a Mrs I've got to
put my time somewhere else
um so I'll play snooker a lot I play
golf get out on the course a lot my
friends love love golf and snooker so
it's perfect yeah they're always up for
it love it um would you ever be a coach
or a pundit
yeah I think I'd be a coach I don't know
if I'd be a pundit I don't think I
couldn't sit there and slag players off
yeah I don't like it when I see that
um did you get something yeah yeah does
it hurt when you hear that it's like
it's it's it's life isn't it like every
Panda has their own opinion so
um I'd want to be a coach I think yeah I
think I'd like to be a coach I would
like to be a manager to be honest yeah
yeah what kind of manager can you be
what's your style I'll be a ball playing
I'd have full backs flying on both of us
don't worry about coming back
um play two up top therefore nice get
the ball in the Box yeah I'd like to
start it on League level and then to
sort of try and work my way up I think
that'd be quite cool my brother's a good
coach as well yeah my brother owns a
coaching business so my brother's a
really good coach and my best friend
worked for him as well so I'd have them
too with me there you go any non-league
manager
what's the proudest moment of your
career so far
um
I'd say playing in a World Cup yeah
massive I think obviously making my
debut Premier League debut it's
obviously massive but I think playing in
a major tournament for me was proud yeah
proud moment amazing and then the
toughest moment of your career so far
toughest moment
again
nah toughest moment in terms of what
like playing against players or like
it's been a few moments where I'm sort
of like I remember giving a penalty away
against Tottenham and scoring and stuff
like that but like I'm sort of like a
positive character I sort of don't get
too low and don't get too high I just
sort of if things go wrong then I know
how quickly football changes so try and
not obviously you get down and stuff but
just try and
get your get good people around you give
you good support and move on from it
um more than that who's the most
influential person on your career uh my
dad I'd say yeah my dad's my dad played
the game he knows the game inside out
um so to have someone like that close
that I can trust and speak to about
anything I think he's been a major part
I think my fam my whole family I can
speak to them about anything like so
close with mum and dad my brother plays
footy coaches footy so I can speak
obviously not life's about footy yet
like obviously you've got to have a
balance between having a family life and
football but in terms of football I've
got like my dad who can give me good
good good information and good uh advice
in football so I'd say that yeah I'm
talking of advice what's the best piece
of advice you've ever been given
I think work hard enjoy what you do and
everything you do give your all
especially in my game I think I think
um hard work beats talent for sure and
when you've got both you see players go
to the top so I think always work hard
at what you do is is one of the main
main bits of information I'd I'd give to
a young Matty cash growing up or a young
college student that wants to be a pro
work hard at what you do enjoy it and
every time you're on the pitch every
time you're in the gym live your life
properly and do it right amazing you
obviously played at the 2022 World Cup a
call-up came along I didn't necessarily
foresee how did that come about
yeah to be fair it's been in the
fountain obviously my nan and Grandad
born in Poland my mum's polish
um it's sort of been in in the family
for ages we've sort of had the
conversation for for years about imagine
like what what if
um and there was the president of Poland
didn't want me they're the first
president that was the last president
that was there he didn't want me because
I didn't speak Polish or whatever the
that's that's up to him that's fair
enough
and a new president come in
and I think they had a conversation with
the manager Paolo Susu is the manager at
the time and I just had a phone call one
day yeah just like
um I think I missed the call I was
training and he left me a message to say
Matty it's um Paulo Susa the Poland
manager can you call me when you get a
minute and I was like yeah yeah so I
called him and he just said listen we
really want you here and um we're gonna
do everything we can to to get you a
passport as quick as we can
um and then yeah the president got me a
passport within within like two weeks
normally takes about six months
yeah
and we had the um playoff games for the
World Cup coming up
I think it was in there I think there
was a br there was a World Cup um uh
International break
on one month and then I think four
months later it was a World Cup maybe a
bit longer no no longer than that but I
only had one I think break before the
World Cup
um World Cup qualifier sorry confusing
myself here and yeah it just sort of
like got done really quickly he said we
want you in before the qualifiers happen
so yeah it got done and I went in and
they've made me feel great is it true
that your mum taught you a few phrases
and a few words before Gan to Camp yeah
yeah I think yeah when when I got the
passport yeah we went over some bits but
it's such a difficult language yeah so
hard to learn I sort of had a I had a
Polish teacher for six months
I don't think I'll learn anything
in school with French for years I can't
say why I'd literally like have a lesson
and then after the lesson I'm thinking
where do I start I can't even remember I
can say hello I can say little things I
can say like like yeah just like
day-to-day life stuff yeah exactly I
don't know about you but like usually um
I remember when I was younger because I
speak Persian as well I used to get
talked I swear words straight away like
that's the first thing you learned like
you learned but it was that the same for
you to be fair I knew them anyway yeah
every time I give the ball away they
said oh I can say it in the world on the
pitch you obviously all communicating
polish so did you have to learn those
phrases yeah but when you're on the
pitch you don't sort of like you speak
but you don't like I think we don't
really communicate in Polish on the
pitch I don't think you just sort of
play you don't really like speak they'll
say like left right if I'm checking my
shoulders or part like you don't when
you pass the ball you don't shout pass
yeah yeah maybe say man on but you sort
of I say that in English to them and
they speak English anyway sir yeah how
are they quite welcoming towards like
obviously from their perspective a
fairly English bloke coming into the
camp were they welcoming yeah yeah
really welcome them yeah to be fair the
whole country's been amazing with me
yeah since I've been there like they
always they always make me feel welcome
um the players are great with me the
staff were great obviously we got a new
manager now
um so I'm looking forward to going in to
work with them but yeah honestly it's
been it's been really good there and
what was the first training session like
was it tough was it different I was in a
box of 11 Dusky yeah first session yeah
yeah it's probably my best session I've
had all years
yeah so uh now it was good yeah I think
we went um we were in Spain for a
training camp when I first met up with
them
and yeah it was it was really good there
how good is Lewandowski close up yeah
his class yeah he's just like he's an
absolute animal to be honest he's
unbelievable his finishing is
and he's always in the he's always in
the right space at the right time like
if he's always in the middle of the box
in the middle of the goal he's in the
box somewhere and you just know he's
gonna score it would you say that he's
the best forward you've ever played with
uh
well I'm not going to leave Ollie
Watkins out no
um
excellent different players yeah no yeah
um yeah I think is is his CV is is he's
a world-class player and he he's like
one of the best has ever been in that
position so
I think yeah he is probably the best
psycho I've played with because because
of his CV um not disrespecting the
strikers that I play with played with
yeah no he's he's up there he's
obviously yeah he's world class huh and
what's he like off the pitch because
obviously to me he strikes me is like
quite a quiet person to get some of his
job are you talking about like you know
that model professional is that yeah
yeah he's just like he's that he's got
exactly that he he
um he's always first on the pitch last
to leave he lives his life right and
he's 34. and he's and he's playing the
way he is so it proves how much he looks
after his body and yeah he's he's a a
role model in Poland and so I have
around the team yeah can I ask you a
question about Lewandowski
there's one aspect to him that I'm not
particularly fond of how do you feel
about his tick tocks oh yeah yeah I've
seen him yeah when you're in you can do
what you want so it's really really fair
point and to be fair you let him off
because it was locked down as well yeah
a lot of his tick-tocks were you doing
it as well yeah
[Laughter]
I don't actually have an account or
anything I don't make tick tocks but
when I'm at home bored I just scroll on
it for an hour
any of the other players in the Polish
Camp before joining it yeah uh klich
Mateus Clips misses me
um I played against him for years
against Leeds Forest it was obviously a
big battle and we had loads of games to
be honest against them
um and he messaged me when it come out
on the in the Press he just said Is it
true as I said yeah yeah so obviously he
would welcome him welcoming
um bed in Iraq obviously I knew I played
against neverlar I didn't know any of
them on a personal level just knew that
because I played against him before
um so yeah December really and Jaco as
well because I'm a Bryant fan yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's obviously brilliant
yeah I like motor he's a fantastic
player obviously he got injured
um but yeah I I played I think I played
against him once before yeah and have
you become particularly close to anybody
in the camp like who do you room with
and and all that um yeah to be fair
they're all really like we're all quite
close to be honest we're all
um we're all like mate yeah
um obviously Betty I played with Villa
so we've we've obviously built a
relationship here
um yeah and sort of yeah badly I'd say
yeah and clips here we're all good
friends huh yeah
um just going on to the Nations League
of course you scored um in that 2-2 draw
what was that feeling like just scoring
for Poland yeah it was a bit of a relief
actually because
um
I sort of wanted to as a as an attack in
fullback
um people talk about stats a lot and um
I sort of wanted to get my first goal
out the way there you know obviously
it's a nice feeling when you get get
your first goal for obviously club and
Country
um and again it's obviously Holland as
well was a a big game as well it was
obviously a away at Holland yeah and it
was just a good feeling yeah it was
probably one of the best feelings I've
had sort of relief just to score yeah
and you've been trying to learn the
language and I think you're doing okay
you were quite self-deprecating which is
a nice quality but I think you're quite
good and I also didn't realize and ask
me do you know what I was going to do I
think there could be a bafta coming to
you oh what a bafta I think you're an
excellent actor and linguist okay yeah
check out this clip
[Music]
National
do they pray before that well how does
that will come about yeah now I am
I went over there on I think I can't
remember what day it was I went over and
had to do two sort of filmings and it
was it was really good actually I
enjoyed it yeah it was just um
in a in a house obviously coming down a
chimney pretending to be Santa as you do
um yeah and then the other one was the
the dog one I think it was no it was
good it was actually nice to do
something different yeah a bit of acting
it's better than my football skills can
you see yourself become an actor in the
future
[Laughter]
it took me a day and a half to learn the
lyric just one word that was a few no
that was it it was a big advert you got
the old address
if Poland played England who do you
think your dad supports
Poland yeah do you know that do you do
you know that ain't gonna support
England if I'm playing no chance yeah no
Poland yeah and obviously mum's yeah mum
polish yeah my mom loves it yeah
um when you line up at the tunnel in the
World Cup
um were you able to take it all in what
was like do you have to Ping yourself is
it I mean I'm in the world I'm at the
World Cup yeah people like I've had a
lot of a lot of questions like that
um and sort of when you're there you cut
like it's hard to take him because
you're like so focused on your job and
obviously you get when you before the
day after you play and obviously the
week you sort of get a bit of time to
yourself to relax but you're sort of in
the moment you know what I mean it's
sort of hard to take it in especially on
game day like playing in a World Cup
everyone's watching you just want to do
well so the adrenaline and all that and
all the obviously you obviously get a
little bit nervous as well
um just try and do do your best on the
pitch rather than taking everything in I
wish you could take it all in but yeah
it was hard to and when you get back and
you sort of speak about it you obviously
take it and you've obviously played in a
major tournament so that's when you take
it in there I was at the Argentina
Poland game oh yeah I was at that yeah I
thought it was brilliant tough day
but ultimately ended in Triumph yeah
yeah for you yeah the main the main aim
was to qualify yeah yeah definitely and
we've done that sir did you think
were you aware because I was in the
stands and I think that in all of all
matches I've ever been to across the
world
Argentina's support oh I've never known
anything like it incredible were you
aware of that on the pitch yeah yeah I
think before before the game kicked off
like the stadium was pretty much full
full of like Argentine fans
um yeah they were I think they were
probably the best fans in the tournament
I'd say yeah definitely they were
obviously when we played against them
they've got the players they have and it
made it even harder to play with the
fans so yeah no wonder they went on to
win it yeah
um and of course we've all seen on
social media you've got the shirt of
mbappe one of Messi as well firstly why
are they here and why they're not here
they're getting framed they're getting
frames are they yeah okay where are they
going to be in your in your house I'm
not going to say that just in case
security reasons
yeah looking forward to getting them
framed and up yeah yeah how does it go
getting the player like that shot like
how do you at the end of the game do you
just go and have a conversation with
Messi and ask for the shirt or is it a
race because presumably you weren't the
only person on the pitch that wanted the
Lionel Messi shirt now well when the
messy uh when the Argentine and Poland
fixtures come out
um I said to Martin I know straight away
get me that shirt yeah the plug yeah
yeah I like to be fat I didn't advertise
I didn't a chance to speak to him when
we were at the World Cup obviously
because he had games and then after the
game he come up to me and said I've got
you a president
so I was like all right and I was
suddenly thinking what is it he just
said come in the changing room and
follow me so I followed him and he had a
bag and it had messy shirt in it yeah
yeah so that was good and then um the
mbappe one I just said to him towards
the end of the game like the 90th minute
the ball went out and I just said can I
get your shot after he said yeah bro no
worries yeah so then after that he went
off and celebrated or whatever and I
thought I'm just gonna leave it and then
he'd come up to me in the tunnel and
took it off yeah oh man yeah yeah he
remembered you got in early then so you
got him before the full-time whistle
yeah but we like we were like walking I
was just walking off I weren't gonna
bother asking again I just thought
that's it and then he like sent me
jogged over to me and just took it off
and I was like Sam yeah gentlemen yeah I
know yeah do you have a big collection
at home all yeah I got a collection yeah
I've got a few good ones yeah I got um
Memphis depay when we played Holland uh
Lewandowski got me a Bayern Munich one
uh JT Got Me A Sign Chelsea one I'm a
captain armband and then them two to add
on yeah plus so I might have to take it
yeah yeah yeah yeah actually collection
that so are you saying that Killian and
Pepe's got a sign Matty Kesha hanging up
in his game yeah he probably used it to
clean the car or something
do you get a real shirt though yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it also you have nothing to wear yeah
yeah
um and then going on to
um playing Killian Buffet like what's
the game plan when you face it against
the caliber yeah we watch videos
obviously a few days leading up to the
France game watch videos of him and he
was lightning I think the game we came
on against he didn't start a game only
because they qualified already I think
and he come on and he ripped it up and
we watched the end of that and it was
like Wow and then in the day of the game
I just sat in my room and watched clips
of him
um the sort of how I'm gonna stop him
really and we had a good battle I think
we had a really good uh it was a good
challenge for me I think we had like 1v1
I think there was a few times he sort of
got around me and then a few where I
want to off him
we had a few one-on-one races as well
um
is that what it is with him is it the
pace like you know obviously he's
obviously he's a fantastic footballer
with a brilliant eye for goal and so
many attributes yeah but if it's one
thing from your perspective is it the
pace yeah is his pace is never like I
said before Sterling's rapid when I
played against Sterling he can run but
he is about pays another level yeah yeah
he just shoots off the go and you can't
actually do anything yeah nothing what
did the gaffer say to you what was his
like plan to
[Applause]
I think he wanted me to back off him and
I didn't want to do that give him the
space yeah yeah he wanted me to back off
him
um but I thought if I get tight and
there's less chance of him sort of
running at me so the first like couple I
got tired and it was fine and then there
was a few where he gains gains a yard
and you can't do anything about it
um but I wanted to go tighter I sort of
yeah that was it and Bape or Messi who
was a harder challenge
well Messi was the other side of the
pitch so I'd say on Bape I think Messi's
quality is speaks for itself is wait a
pass the way he controls the boys
obviously I don't need to sit here and
explain Messi but I think for me and
Mappo was the hardest test yeah would
you say that Lionel Messi is the goat
yeah I think so yeah I think
difficult in it because like them to him
and Ronaldo have done it at the top for
years and years 15 20 well however many
years they've done it so it's hard to
sort of single out one I think they're
both
um they're both goats yeah yeah and
who's the toughest player you faced at
the World Cup just generally was it one
of those two Yeah Yeah by far yeah yeah
definitely I'll tell you he's the
toughest yeah and international football
tournament football like that compared
to your everyday challenges at Aston
Villa is there a huge difference playing
in playing style do you find it very
different playing International
Tournament football compared to Premier
League yeah it's different obviously
because you've got different managers
different players so different styles
like of course there's different styles
um and I think International Football is
a little bit more
I wouldn't say slower but it's a little
bit more
um not tactical it's hard to say it's
still it's obviously top because every
every player that's playing is the best
in the country that's why they're
playing for the country so they're all
top players it's different yeah it's
different Premier League's like really
fast and like energetic and
so I mean quick players everywhere and
like you know what I mean so I'm not
saying there's not that in international
it's just a little bit different and he
talked about Emmy Martinez earlier um
what's he been like coming back from
obviously winning the World Cup is he
different now he's got you know man he's
been brilliant yeah he's been class yeah
um Emmy is a character life we saw in
the celebrations he's such a character
he's like that in training yeah yeah
he's insane yeah like if you miss and
you're if you're on his side you're
buzzing but if you're on the other side
and you lose and he saves he's laughing
at you he'll give you something yeah and
I only like joking yeah
he's amazing yeah he's such a good
goalie about it since he's been back
he's been brilliant so I know he's all
about Mind Games isn't he yeah yeah if
he's doing that in training yeah
and he doesn't even like when people say
it's taking it he's not doing it to be
personal like he does it in training to
us boys so I think it's just his way of
trying trying to win I think yeah and
it's amazing what he achieved there it's
really like the way that he the way that
he contributed to that yeah he changed
the way that I spoke about penalties
without me even realizing you know
usually when a player steps up to take a
penalty I'll always go do you think
he'll score yeah yeah when Jimmy Martin
is in goal I'll go do you think you'll
save it yeah I've kind of look at it
yeah and like I see it every day like
when we do penalties quite a lot and he
obviously don't save everyone but he's
like he's a big goal isn't he yeah and
in the World Cup he's obviously proved
that yeah and has he put his medal in
has he let you ever yeah he brought his
medal in yeah his first day yeah yeah
come back and just obviously we
congratulated him and he showed us it
and that yeah because I don't know I
don't know if you struggling McAllister
obviously got that big yeah I've seen it
celebrations amazing no he had a yeah he
had a good welcome yeah yeah it wasn't
like what I seen at Brighton that was
brilliant to be fair
um but now all the lads and that wished
him like said well done and obviously
the coaching staff as well and yeah
we've obviously I think we had a game a
few days later when he come back so we
were just focused on that but yeah he's
been definitely one of the best
goalkeepers in the world at the moment
yeah yeah for sure I'd say he is
probably yeah I think he is and he's
just won the World Cup
basically not one admit but he's
obviously done major
impact on them winning the World Cup I
think he's he's up there with the best
in the world yeah love it what we're
gonna do now Matty is we're going to
play a game
it's called Cash in or cash out yeah
we're going to give you a series of
various scenarios yeah and you take what
I do yeah tell us where you do it or not
right okay so this is the scene right
it's the World Cup final it's tool and
it's 89th minute right you're running
through one-on-one yeah okay you see
Lewandowski he's on a hat trick by the
way all right he's just scored two yeah
do you go for goal or do you pass it
down
oh he's got a tapping in he no yeah if I
slide it there is it yeah and he's got
he's called actually and I've got 50 50
chance and we're winning the game as
well I'm sliding it yeah really yeah
see I for one if I miss yeah he's gonna
it's too old he's gonna go back though
I'm sliding it yes your cash out yep
cash out yeah right scenario two for you
here Aston Villa Captain John mcginn
proposes a golf tournament amongst a
squad the winner I'm winning that really
do you think so yeah so the winner is
free from all player fines for a year
but anyone outside the top five has to
pay double fines for the rest of the
year yeah
you cash in in or cash in out of that
tournament
I'm I'm cashing in because I know I'm
gonna win it so you'll you are
definitely undoubtedly winning the top
five golf players I'm top so you've
actually changed you know that so I'm
still free yeah I'm a free
um playoffs though is it yeah good but
like I have to give him lessons to be
good
who's up there I think everyone in the
Villa Squad yeah who's that would say
I'm the best golfer at the club not
being big-headed but I am
who's your Challenger who's who's
challenges there's a few that have tried
to get better Ollie Watkins when I first
played with him God it took about eight
hours have you got a group WhatsApp yeah
yeah well it called a avfc golfers yeah
if you were to put a message in that
WhatsApp group now saying Lads am I the
best what would come back what are you
on about Kashi yeah
am I the best they'll be like what are
you on about now like I'm the number so
if I were to ask anyway like parallel
universe yeah as I'm on a train back to
London Tyron Mings is there if I were to
just happen I'm really sorry just very
quick question who's your best golfer
yeah you guarantee it yeah all right I'm
going to put this to the test 100 at
some point in my life I will come across
an estimated player yeah I thought you
knew this I'm well I'm known for being
what did you just nearly say well pass
it did you no not Worldcraft
but I'm known for being good at golf in
the football in like yeah yeah yeah
Community yeah yeah you're known as one
the best yeah yeah all right any
football player watching this right now
on a golf day yeah oh yeah yeah
it's good yeah yeah who's the best other
footballer you've played with either
you've gone out on a golf course you've
got to go God he's good
um best have a good golfer footballer
for himself probably I think I've never
played with War Powers but I'm hearing
he's he's good at golf and he's set up
in it yeah yeah well if he's any good as
he freaking obviously at Villa we had
Danny ings was was decent
Ashley Young plays Ming's plays uh Ollie
Watkins we've got a group chat that we
all go out and play but I don't think
they like playing with me because it's
like you're too good is there somebody
else they've obviously started recently
they're all decent they can all lit it
and they can like play and um I don't
get the invites who's the worst is there
like clearly somebody struggling now
they can all play you know there's not
like one that's crap the only like he's
not coming today
they're all decent but I think yeah I'm
probably the best golfer all right we're
gonna put you to the test I'm sure all
right final scenario okay uh it's a
Christmas party you're not gonna karaoke
bar all right by the way oh yeah but
I'll start that again
um
right so you're out for Christmas party
you're in a karaoke bar right Tara Ming
says you have to do it duet Nelly and
Kelly dilemma right great tune by the
way are you cash in or cash out
depends how many I've had
she finds yourself on the karaoke oh no
yeah I'll give it a go yeah cash in yeah
yeah what should go through karaoke song
um Robbie Williams Oh which one Angels
yeah how does that go I said away yeah
[Laughter]
in the room with me
yeah we've got you've got Mike already
so yeah you're halfway there right
um let's let's put it all the way back
uh back to when you started out in
London Forest um you spent some time at
Wickham uh but came for it for us a
winner at the time uh were you always a
winner growing up sorry
yeah
uh yeah nah it was like my time at
Forest was amazing I had the best years
um obviously grew up there comforted not
grew up I'm from London but I come
through the academy there and played
obviously my first professional sort of
footballer
um so yeah I've got nothing positive
I've got nothing not positive to say
about Forest it's amazing
um and and obviously when the charts
come to move to Villa it was obviously a
going from the champ to the Prem so it
was obviously a big move and everyone
sort of understood it like everyone the
fans the club they knew that I sort of
wanted to go
and try and prove myself in the Prem so
um for all parties it was it was fine
and ever since I've gone I still have
Forest fans messaging me now pretty much
every day just like wishing me well and
and um yeah it was it was good as well
when I went back it was nice to see
everyone and and say hello so yeah now
amazing time there yeah were you clearly
the best player in your school
uh nah I don't know really I don't think
I don't know I love playing I just
wanted to play football and I remember
like I weren't the brightest at school I
didn't really want to do school kids
don't listen to that
um I just sort of wanted to play
football and like everything I'd done
was just to try and be a footballer so I
obviously got the chance to go to
college like a football college at Fab
Academy
um and I didn't get any grades at school
so like I missed the education part
there because normally when you go
College you have to do like education as
well as what you're doing I think
um and I just trained every day and it
ended up getting getting into Forest so
yeah I'm pretty sure in America that you
can't unless you pass your tests yeah
you can't would you like to see
something like that introduce there or
do you think it's a bit too much what
way that isn't like you have to pass
your test to be able to play yeah well I
think
um
no I think because there's there's
players out there that haven't got the
opportunity to be in an academy that
ain't right like that maybe not be as
good academically as what other people
are so I think
if you're naturally good at football
um not saying I'm naturally good at
football I mean in terms of if if you
can't get the grades or whatever I think
this
it's been at the right place at the
right time and lucky I sort of fell into
that category yeah your dad was a pro as
well wasn't it was that a help or did
that add pressure to you no I never
added pressure to me I think he sort of
strived me on really
um because obviously when I was at
Wickham we'd playing I was obviously
under 15s 14s and he used to drive all
over the country for me so the pressure
was to not play well and then get back
and have to do running around the green
they used to live around it was quite
harsh on me with that um but no he never
added pressure to me like really it sort
of made me want to be better if anything
and then talking obviously going from a
Winger to right back I think it was
Sabri La Mucci uh forest and put you as
a right back yeah was that the kind of
moment you thought yeah I think this is
for me now I want to be a right back
rather than be a Winger yeah I remember
like when sadbury came in
I've got a really good relationship with
Sabra even now he still calls me now we
speak quite a lot
um and I remember he come in and Jimmy
Gilligan sadbury just got the job and we
had a we had a friendly game it was
pre-season against alverton and Jimmy
Gilligan was the 23s manager so he took
that ganks obviously just got appointed
and he just said
um cash are you going to play right back
and I played on the wing and in Midfield
previously
so I was like obviously new managers are
here why am I playing there like and I
think them two must have had a
conversation about me moving there and I
was like all right so anyway I played
had a good game
um and then the manager obviously come
in the next day had a meeting with him
and he just pulled me and said listen I
want you to pay right back and then from
then on I just started the first game
and played every game there were you
happy to do that yeah yeah I loved it
like as soon as I started playing it I
think the first game of the season was
against West Brom at home I scored and
like everyone was like oh like it was
right back it's been the worst Winger in
the league before
and then then I just started enjoying it
and then obviously I had a season and
then I moved to Villa after that oh
seeing as him as that obviously changed
your career by obviously Villa can you
call in yeah yeah um how did that move
come about the villain move
um so I was on holiday
signed the new contract in January at
Forest I had four years I signed a new
four-year dealer and then
um obviously I had a really good season
so I sort of had a few calls from a few
clubs Mage and
and we went away to
um went away to Turkey and I was on
holiday there and uh my phone I think
Fulham had spoke to me agent and stuff
and and obviously because I loved their
Forest but the opportunity was as I said
to go to the next level
um and then I had to call from Villa on
the last day of the holiday just said
listen we really want you and that was
it it got done quite quickly I come back
and then I went back reported back to
Forest I'd like a bit of pre-season
training and then it got done within a
week yeah and you know how you speak so
glowingly about forests and your time
there yeah does Aston Villa now have the
same sort of feeling uh within you like
yeah yeah you're at home there yeah I
feel at home yeah I love it there yeah
although we I'll always speak highly of
forest because it was an amazing Club I
came through the ranks there and it was
obviously massive for me and the fans
were always amazing with me so and I'm
getting that feeling with Villa as soon
as I arrived they made me feel the fans
have been brilliant with me the club's
fantastic it's a massive Club I really
enjoy being here I love my love my
football here so hopefully it can
continue and obviously linking up with
Steven Gerard you're of an age where
Stephen Gerrard is an icon of the
Premier League that must have been like
really inspiring to play for him yeah
yeah I've had like I've been lucky
really obviously how JT as a coach at
Villa obviously the year before
um and then yeah obviously working with
the likes of Gerard I bought built a
really good relationship with him
um and he was really good with me so
um
yeah a lot I love playing under him and
it was fantastic yeah amazing and have
you noticed a big difference just in
terms of perhaps approach in terms of
styles between Emery and Gerard yeah I
think every manager that comes in or
goes into a job has got a different
style that's why you see managers come
and go and change a lot
um and yeah it's a difference yeah
there's obviously different as I said
different tactics different ways of how
we want to play
um and yeah I'm loving life under undone
I am Marie so hopefully that can
continue for a long time and it's
recently come out obviously the polling
job's not now available but he was
linked with it would you would you have
liked to have linked up with him again
in the Poland Squad yeah I think
obviously I've seen it come out I didn't
know how true it was or whatever
um but yeah obviously we've got a new
manager now so hopefully
um we can we can do well under him yeah
you used to work in River Island other
clothing labels are available
um
did you ever think when you were working
at River Island that you would go on to
become a premier league footballer like
did you always believe that you were
going to make it to the very top of the
game or was it more of a hope
uh more of a hope yeah
like yeah I think if you ask any 16 17
year old lad now are you going to play
in the Premier League they wouldn't be
able to answer what branch of River
Island were you in isn't the lady
section yeah customers in
did you ask you asked to me
in the ladies section please
uh now is that what you mean what
section was I in well no that was
interesting what what was in Windsor
yeah so in the Windsor River Island yeah
Daniels was next door was a toy like a
you ever heard of Daniel it's like a toy
shot it's got everything it's a bit like
Harrod but not as big as Harrod does
everything so lights like um closed
section toy section sports section and
all that and I was in the toy shop there
yeah stacking this stuff working two
jobs yeah yeah I had that on a Saturday
and then toy shop on a Sunday whilst
training yeah in Monday to Friday
training yeah after yeah Mama made me um
a pocket money yeah that's class yeah
what was your actual role so I know you
work in the women's section but what are
we doing folding clothes yeah just
folding clothes stock room yeah putting
labels on clothes like getting
deliveries in stacking the shelves doing
all what you'd see you know like being
completely honestly like you're Wicked
fullback were you Wicked at stacking
shell when you
upstairs and it was the dustiest like
like it was so dusty up in the stockroom
and they used to come home I used to
have dust all over my face so I wouldn't
like that now
but I reckon I could I used to take my
phone off I'll go on my phone what was
it
well was there any like moment or any
kind of memory that sticks out whilst
you're working like a funny story you
could tell us or anything that's working
in the toy shop Yeah well yeah or in
River Island or either all
working in a toy shop yeah this is a mad
line of questioning we have we have a
Poland International just got back from
a World Cup the current Premier League
player tell me about this you know I've
worked in River Island and places yeah
exactly
fans are asking for it funny stories no
I don't think I've got funny stories I
think when they hit five o'clock when he
used to shout he's just run out the door
[Laughter]
um I used to enjoy it to be honest like
obviously I didn't know what the life of
a like a professional footballer was
like but I I used to enjoy going to work
on a Saturday I used to drive a polo
just fill my car up and then I left to
work again to earn it back I love it
um but now I I enjoyed it yeah and
obviously it's I think everything I've
done over the past has sort of got me to
this moment so that was obviously part
of it so okay just just before
um we let you go do you think you could
try and teach Maz one polish expression
yeah
I'll get there again too
we're so grateful to having you thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
people oh you're hard on mine up we
didn't win those games right fact the
eight games that were remaining were
arguably the best run of games on paper
so that was only what I couldn't get I
was like well that's the best run and
you're taking this out two days before
the best run well if you've got a lap
dance you'd have to spin again so it's
your fine to get the number of so when
you do the lap dance genius